وحصلت الجزيره على صور صادمه لمجزره
ارتكبها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في جباليه
وذهب ضحيتها اكثر من 100 شهيد بينهم
مجموعه اطفال من عائلتي سليمان
والبرش هؤلاء
شهداء ال البرش وال
سليمان في مجزره في جبال
البلد هذان الطفلان هم
توامان وهذه الطفله
الجميله لا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله
عليها نحيا وعليها نموت وبها نلقى
الله اللهم انا استودعناك
ابنائنا وتقبلهم في
عليين اللهم خذ من دمائنا
واجسادنا وابنائنا حتى
ترضى اللهم
انا
تركناهم اليك اغفر لنا
ولهم لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
العليم معنا من جباليه دكتور منير البرشه
المدير العام لوزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
بدايه تعزينا في هؤلاء ولربما منهم اقارب
لك بشكل او باخر لست متاكده ولكن من عائله
البرش ايضا
فتعزيز ان تضعنا دكتور في صوره هذا الوضع
في مخيم جبالي الذي يتكرر
استهدافه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تصورت
هؤلاء الاطفال بالليل وكنت يعني اشاهد هذه
الطفوله وهؤلاء كيف هو بنك الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هذا البنك الاهداف الذي يدعيه
نتنياهو وبايدن قتل اطفالنا الشهداء وصل
حتى الان منهم ما يقارب 55 شهيد يعني
الاجمالي 110 110 حتى
نحدد
المعلومه 110 من الشهداء خلال 24 ساعه
مجزره ال البرش وال
علوان وهؤلاء الاطفال 55
شهيد
الحقيقه يعني الاحتلال يمعن في هذه
المجازر بالامس في مدينه جباليه اي استهدف
عائله شهاب وهذه العائله قدمت 65 شهيد في
بدايه الحرب والبارحه 24 شهيد عائله جنيد
عائله عائلات كثيره من العائلات الكريمه
في جبال علوان
سليمان عائلات طيبه معروفه وعائله خله كان
الشاهد فيها ان هؤلاء الاطفال وامهم كانوا
يصلون كانت امهاتهم تصلي قيام الليل
فماتوا سجدا وال خله في الصباح ماتوا ركعا
من النساء الحقيقه الاحتلال بعد
مجازره في مستشفى كمال عدوان وهذه جريمه
الحرب التي فعل لها اي كنا حضرنا انه
سيفعل جريمه اخرى في مستشفى العوده حاصر
الليله مستشفى العوده وهو
مستشفى تخصصي للولاده وايضا للجراحات
المتخصصه في جراحات الكسور والعظام
وبمكون ناد على جميع الطواقم الصحيه ا
اعتقل مدير عام مستشفى العوده الدكتور
احمد مهنا ام ك الاحتلال بكون اعتقل
الدكتور احمد مهنا مدير مستشفى العوده
الدكتور احمد الكحلوت مدير عام مستشفى
كمال عدوان وعلى راسهم الدكتور محمد ابو
سلميه مدير عام مستشفى الشفاء ايضا
الاحتلال
بالتوازي قصف مبنى الجراحات التخصصيه في
مستشفى
الشفاء وكانت لنا محاولات لاعاده تشغيل
هذا المستشفى الاحتلال يسبقنا بخطوه
وخطوات لتصفيه المنظومه الصحيه وبالتوازي
ايضا
قصف مستشفى ناصر في خانيونس الاحتلال
يتعمد قصف المستشفيات كما احدث الجريمه
النكراء بالامس في مستشفى كمال عدوان
عندما خرج منها وحفر حفره كبيره ودفن فيها
وجرف فيها الشهداء والمعلومات تؤكد لدينا
انه جرف حتى المصابين لاننا تركنا اكثر من
65 مصاب
في المستشفى ومنهم استشهد 12 الاحتلال
نؤكد على جرفهم ووضعهم في هذه الحفره
وبقيه
الجرحى فقدناهم لم نجدهم حتى اللحظه ام
فلذلك الاهالي والكوادر الطبيه تؤكد لنا
انهم سمعوا اصواتا في جرف المصابين داخل
هذه الحفر التي حفرها داخل مستشفى كمال
عدوان هذه جريمه حرب بمعنى الكلمه يراد
بها قتل كل انسان فلسطيني وقتل متعمد
فلذلك نحن نطالب بتحقيق دولي في هذه
الجريمه الاحتلال لا يترك لنا مجالا مجالا
واحدا الا ويدمر هذه المم
قتل اكثر من 300 من كوادرنا
الطبيه اعتقل اكثر من
39 من اي الكوادر الطبيه قتل 58 طبيب 26
طبيب اسنان 30 من الزملاء الصيادله 24
مسعف 13 من التحاليل الطبيه 94 ممرض قتل
اخصائي العيون اكثر من سته من الاخصائي
العيون واخصائي الاشعه ثلاثه والاداريين
17 الاحتلال يعني لا يترك مجالا لنا الا
ويريد تصفيه هذه هذا النظام الصحي في قطاع
غزه ويقطع امل الناس بان يتداوى او يذهب
الى المستشفيات فالان لا يوجد غرفه عمليات
واحده تعمل في شمال ومدينه غزه وبعدما
استهدف المستشفى المعمداني بالامس نعم
اصبحت شمال غزه او شمال قطاع غزه لا تجرى
به عمليه جراحيه واحده وهذا امر خطير جدا
ما نفعله في مراكزنا التي نعمل فيها هي
نقاط طبيه تعمل على الاسعافات الاوليه
والعمليات المتوسطه لكن ه هل يعقل ان لا
تجرى عمليات جراحيه كان الله بالعون كان
الله بالعون نشكرك من جبال يادكتور منير
البرش المدير العام لوزاره الصحه في قطاع
غزه